[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce sillon
parler sport spécial halloween à pour ce
troisième numéro de la saison on garde
la recette qui a fait la renommée de
s'auto qu'il y aura comme d'habitude des
analyses des débats et des duels avec
nos chroniqueurs ils sont quatre autour
de cette table
aujourd'hui présentation sur le thème
d'halloween bien sûr et oui c'est la
période
on commence à ma droite c'est le dracula
du cyclisme et vampirise tous les titres
master s'il était déjà champion d'europe
il est toujours le champion du monde de
cyclisme sur piste master's la star du
de rire mais capital ian dujarrier piste
à au club de vélizy et avec sa monture
michael vous avez rien dans votre
chapeau j'ai rien à mon chapeau même pas
les titres
s'il ya une maillot partie du maillot
jaune le maillot bravo en tout cas on
passe de l'autre côté un musique c'est
notre sorcière bien aimée elle arrive à
nous envoûter avec ses figures de pole
dance incroyable et terriblement sexy
un sport qu'elle pratique à versailles à
la fois aller à la fois envoûtante
surprenante année les temps me tenaient
les notre ambassadrice de charme
hélène de la grange comment allez-vous
et leur montrait bien on en perd ses
mots est ce qu'on peut recevoir je
jouais tous les entraînements sont ravis
d'y perdre et des heureux tout dire
merci et les cornes ça marche toujours
que ça fait toujours un défi on passe de
l'autre côté musique qu'il a la force
d'un loup garou et la psychologie d'un
freddy krueger il nous vient tout droit
de versailles pour
un mot des tours pierre chevallier du
rugby-club de versailles est avec nous
pendant une heure pierre chevallier
commence à lui jack sparrow michael
salut à tous super cheveux tient bien
passé je suis passé chez le coiffeur je
me suis fait deja des rajouts voilà
l'impression de tomber dans une
thématique harry potter en ruine avec
moi j'ai gravi jacob on termine de
l'autre côté à musique c'est notre
citrouille à nous notre gentil gritche
il va vous faire frissonner ou pas
pendant cette émission la légende le miz
notre super chroniqueurs spécialistes
rugby coach jean nice est avec nous avec
un super masque aujourd'hui vous fait
très peur aux gens on va matin moins de
18 ans pour pour l'émission édition
oui oui je ne marche pas toujours
anniversaire c'est une date un peu
spécial aujourd'hui quand on est une
date un peu spéciale et on va progresser
dans l'émission je suis désolé alors
avant de passer au thème de l'émission
je vous propose de reprendre notre
sérieux messieurs et mesdames on va
parler des jo de 2024 le logo officiel a
été dévoilé dans un rond doré
symbolisant une médaille d'or on voit
une flamme olympique
celle ci laisse également apparaître un
visage stylisé représentant marianne
l'allégorie de la république française
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
les créateurs veulent donner une
identité total l'événement et apporter
une touche révolutionnaire le montant
total investi dans ce logo n'a pas été
un révélé je rappelle pour que ce logo
sera à bord et dans les yvelines le
département va accueillir le vtt et le
bmx le cyclisme sur piste et
l'équitation le pentathlon moderne et le
golf sur son territoire une réaction
autour de sa table sur ce logo
on aime ou on n'aime pas déjà vous
mettez vous n'aimez pas j'ai j'aime pas
et le pire c'est que à part la couleur
je me doutais que réunit sorte de
flammes dans le
dans le logo de la france est autant
j'étais fan du logo de la ville
candidate de parts et 2024 avec ce 24 et
s'est informé en forme de tour eiffel
là je me retrouve pas mais mais plus je
le vois et plus je lui trouve des l'ailé
mais pour 2020 de 40 bien sûr mais c'est
vrai qu'à pro premier abord jeu il ne
fait pas vibrer voilà non mais non voilà
après c'est vraiment personnellement ça
c'est les goûts et de couleurs
mais c'est vrai qu'il va première vue
comme sa première chaussette je suis pas
super fan de de ceux de ce logo hélène
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de ce logo
moi j'aime bien par contre je pense
qu'on aurait peut-être dû ne pas mettre
la bouche pour faire moins féminin mais
qu'on devine puces ce côté fini à 1 ça
fait un peu combat féministe voilà un
carton rouge
voilà j'en remets ton fils du mask
je pense qu'elle est peut-être pas
besoin de surfer miniser le
le logo déjà la flamme avec le doré
autour on voit déjà que c'est féminin
après c'est un joli look ou non j'aime
bien j'aime bien avec ce petit bémol
pierre j'aime bien des j'aime bien sur
deux points le premier c'est le parti
pris le parti pris à explication entre
la médaille d'or
le marianne et il y avait un troisième
la flamme la flamme olympique donc
j'aime j'aime bien ce parti pris et
j'aime bien le deuxième point c'est que
c'est que ce soit un logo qui va être
qui va être comment aux jeux olympiques
et paralympiques et ce qui est une
première dans l'histoire de la delà du
graphisme des tellement cher je voudrais
plus sanglant en faire un deuxième
c'est donc j'aime bien partie pays hôte
mais et pour aller dans le sens de ce
que disait nietzsche justement moi je
suis content qu'ils soient allés au fond
du au fond du système vous aimez bien à
chipoter un peu révolutionnaire
oui ou allongés original volontairement
volontairement positionner en
l'occurrence et donc après moi il faudra
assumer surtout clés sur toutes les
consoles en ce2 ce2 seul aux gens vous
aimez bien vous oui oui pour moi
sobriété efficacité modernisme mais ce
que je trouve bien parce que les jeux
sont déjà un petit peu réussi quand on
voit ce genre selon mais ça fait partie
de la communication un logo ça lance les
jeux ça fait partie de la communication
donc durer une identification peut être
simplifié vous être favorisée par ce
biais là le fait qu'on ne voit pas non
comme il faisait comme le rappelait yann
en avait on avait dans le logo de la
ville candidate paris 2024 la tour
eiffel avec les couleurs olympiques je
pense pas qu'on me pose quand il marque
et paris devienne 2024 ne pas besoin de
rappeler un symbole parisien alors au
contraire rappeler un symbole fort ou en
symbole national travers la marianne et
olympique avec la flamme priori tout est
dit alors je rappelle que le vtt degrés
est est organisé sur la colline
d'elancourt le cyclisme sur piste au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
le bmx sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines le golf au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
évidemment l'équitation et le pentathlon
moderne à versailles et sûrement les
épreuves de cyclisme sur route dans les
yvelines
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler du tour de france 2020 qui
passera par les ivy nous font également
un coup de projecteur sur la transat
jacques vabre laurent polito louis
burton
va participer à cette course au large
mais avant de développer ces thèmes
on va parler au golf on continue donc
par du golfe l'open de france s'est
déroulé du 17 au 20 octobre sur le golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
ce dimanche 20 octobre le belge nicolas
colsaerts disposer de trois coups
d'avancé avant d'aborder le dernier tour
le joueur de 36 ans a réussi à conserver
son avance nicolas colsaerts remporte au
trou numéro 18 cette édition 2010 9 son
premier titre depuis sept ans le golfeur
termine 12 coups sous le par avec un
coup d'avancé
on écoute ses réactions c'est énormément
de joueurs
voilà ça fait ça fait 18 ans que je suis
pro j'ai gagné deux fois j'ai dû gagner
plus souvent comme je l'aï déjà dit
souvent le fait de gagner chez vous
c'est génial j'ai joué un peu
l'impression de faire partie du paysage
golfique français de leur côté à les
français n'ont une fois de plus pas
réussi à dompter ce parcours de
l'albatros les chefs de file de la
délégation française
victor à perez et benjamin hebert
termine 16e en moins 4 c'est un parcours
que je connais bien qui me résiste
souvent donc cette année je suis content
parce que j'ai quand même réussi à faire
une bonne semaine
nicolas colsaerts est un peu france il a
joué de nombreux tournois en france il a
côtoyé des français sur ces
entraînements également la question sur
ce thème avec cette victoire belge est
ce que c'est un peu une victoire
française finalement oui ou non
oui pour pierre chevallier non pour
enfin un petit duel entre entre jean et
pierre genre vous pensez donc pour vous
c'est pas une victoire française mais
s'ils sont belgique pour franco belge me
fera gobain
mais où va c'est comme certains d'une
technique qui se disent français quoi je
peux passer en régie appelé jacques le 6
mai
whittier belge est très content de cette
victoire des châteaux forts
non pour moi pour moi ils sont belges
donc me franco-belge et palau fargo
belge il est belge il a gagné c'est bien
et voilà c'est on essaie c'est purement
de phrases et ça on essaie à travers sa
de de cacher la pauvreté du jeu actuel
du golfe aux pacsés et non non c'est pas
la france d'égaler c'est la belgique
donc nous nos joueurs nos golfeurs
français malheureusement ça a été dit
dans le reportage
ils ont une fois de plus mais ils ont
quel j'étais devant l'interview de sait
plus comment il s'appelle celui le
golfeur fred hassan 1er benjamin hebert
qui joue en moins de quatre se dit
satisfait bon c'est pas mal il termine
6ème c'est pas mal
il termine 16e voilà bon ciné ça
dissuade terminant 16e ses dires elle a
toujours une petite déception il pouvait
pas faire mieux peut-être sur ce tournoi
donc non ce qui veut dire que nous
sommes très pauvre en qualité de jeu la
qualité le golfeur fradier actuellement
clair moi c'est sûr côté poésie
chevaleresque et sur le l'amour que
porte nicolas colsaerts à la france
effectivement il est belge
lorsque lorsqu'on se rappelle de la
coupe du monde de football on sait qu'on
a eu on a eu des on a eu des petites
inimitiés entre les français les belges
mais c'est quand même une histoire
d'amour qui dure depuis des années et
des années et celle de nicolas colsaerts
avec le golf français et les golfs
français dure depuis au moins pu
longtemps c'est il l'a rappelé et ça
fait 18 ans qui joue qui joue pro il est
très souvent chez nous il connaît par
coeur les golfeurs français et en
effectivement on se satisfait de ça
c'est vrai mais le personnage le
personnage en lui-même est tellement
attachant tellement tellement
authentique tellement fort il est passé
partout partout les tous les états
mentaux au clos si pendant sept ans je
rappelle il ay lattre
versez le désert et c'était souvent en
france c'était souvent les portes du
désert était souvent en france là il ya
qu à voir en fait le l'engouement et
l'attachement qu'il a eu il ya eu pour
pour que le sarthe
pendant les quatre jours de l'open
notamment il était en tête sur les deux
premiers de les deux premiers jours
le dimanche ils se retrouvent ils se
retrouvent un peu relégués derrière un
danois
et puis il fait il fait deux coups de
coups de fils de 12 sur son driver
or voilà la sous-préfète et puis il
repasse en tête aux 17 sur le green du
17 et donc oui oui il n'a pas la
nationalité française mais il a un coeur
français il a il a des amis français
il l'a dit avec une émotion incroyable
sur le sur le green du 18 et puis après
en conférence de presse
ça fait tellement longtemps qu'il
attendait ça fait tellement longtemps
qu'ils nous qui nous drague en fait sur
le feu sur le golf français
et puis on se satisfait de ça sur 7 sur
cette édition de transition en disant
c'est pas un français qui a gagné c'est
pas un français qui a performé on aurait
adoré les voir évidemment c'était une
année pour eux théoriquement mais bah
c'est un francophone qui gagner et moi
j'ai envie d'y voir un joli clin d'oeil
hélène qui vous a convaincu bon genre
aux pierres là je vais dire gens parce
que j'habite à l'heure il a une main
coupée quand même des gens mais non mais
quand même
non merci c'est pas parce que on aime
bien les voir les filles en lames de
conte et hollandais par exemple on parle
de belgique pas d'hollander oui mais
c'est pareil
puis yann couedor d'accord avec jean
c'est typiquement français je me
souviens de mary pierce qui est
américaine quand même à la base que l'on
a rattrapé pour devenir française et je
me souviens d'une blague des des
guignols à l'époque où en fait quand
elle est rentrée sur le court pour c'est
marie-france percée voilà j'avais adoré
cette fameuse blague c'est avec ces
petits livres en français en formulant
en ce moment il ya un jeune un jeune
monégasque qui qui qui performe très
très bien chars leclerc
voilà ça y est il est devenu français je
suis désolé comme philippe gilbert gagné
un monument est au cyclisme pour moi il
est belge il est pas français
donc elle est hors de question de de
dire cocorico quand quand nos français
ont échoué sur 1 sur un tournoi comme
celui c'est comme si après c'est pas une
victoire française qui les français vip
après que jacques de dixmude je le
rappelle est lui assez peu finalement
assez peu de retours de retomber sur le
golf belge et il cotait côté de la baie
de la belgique il ya eu finalement le
moindre tour que que qu'en france sur
ces l'open de france certes mais il n'y
a pas eu trop de récupération sur une
victoire belge à l'open de france
est-ce qu'on se console finalement
est-ce qu'on a finalement finalement
j'arrive et ça je suis d'accord avec
jean ian ces français ces français
s'étaient unis en langage est permis les
18e grégory bourdy terminé 29e victor
dubuisson a terminé 77e alexander levy
n'a même pas passé le cut
finalement on se contente d'un géant
belge qui vient sur le terrain tant du
lycée sans jamais renier jours du jeudi
hébert et
hébert et blanc gars qui étaient bien
placés ils ont fait un bon premier tour
et puis sa clause est derrière avec 1
avec un parcours du golf national qui se
défend extrêmement bien et qui qui les a
haché les uns après les autres
donc là oui oui on se contente de on se
contente de dire que finalement victor
perez et par jean marc hébert qui ont
performé inquiète paris faut quand même
rappeler une compétition de golf c'est
quand même très très non ces quatre
jours c'est du jeudi au dimanche
les mecs passent quatre fois sur le et à
la faim et à la fin ça joue souvent à un
coût c'est c'est très très très régulier
entre le 1er et le 2ème même parfois il
ya un coût supplémentaire sur un trou
pour pouvoir aller séparés c'est pareil
le premier du second c'est c'est quand
même un sport qui est enfin bref c'est
un sprint final mais avec une très très
longue
les dames a jamais fini sur le dernier
tour le dimanche en scène qui était en
tête depuis le depuis le milieu du
dernier tour du quatrième tour fait un
double bogey sur le 17 et colsaerts à
pommes apprend sur le disent est ce
qu'il est repassé en tête
il lui reste un trou à jouer pour
pouvoir remporter nous rapidement un
petit mot sur les français est ce que
finalement c'était l'année où jamais il
n'y avait pas forcément des grosses
têtes d'affiché
rory mcilroy comme il ya eu dans le
passé des justin thomas est ce qu'ils
ont raté le coche finalement romans dont
pour moi ils ont pas raté le coche
puisque encore une fois à -4 et s'estime
c'est peut-être les négociations sera
plus compliqué ces lignes aux tests dans
16 en 10 ans avec thomas levet de l'open
de france parce qu'aujourd'hui je répète
en notre bonne chance en france cette
année c'était à 50 en irak et je pense
que notre d'obstacles dont notre golf
actuellement n'est pas on n'est pas au
niveau
la preuve - 12 pour le wenger en moyenne
4 ps qu'ils ont raté le coche sur 7 sur
cette édition là je ne passe pas je ne
pense pas que les plateaux sont pas sont
pas si relevé que ça il ya eu que
l'année dernière année de prêt ryder cup
il ya eu il ya eu vraiment du monde sur
le parcours du national mais c'est pas
c'est pas des cadors qui gagne c'est bon
c'est quand même joueur de ryder cup
mais quand levé gagnants 2011 il n'y a
pas un plateau ultra ultra relevé
c'est simplement la fibre nationale qui
qui prend le qui prend le relais et
c'était l'année de thomas comme c'était
l'année de remesy deux fois deux fois de
suite avant les années 2010 mais ils
n'ont pas forcément raté le coche
ceci dit uniquement dans les conditions
les conditions il connaissait mieux que
les joueurs des joueurs américains par
exemple aux européens les européens il
aurait pu la vue le contingent il aurait
pu gagner la semaine auraient retenti
juste une petite séquence avant de
refermer cette première thématique
j'aimerais qu'on insiste sur un petit
moment émotion nicolas colsaerts arrive
en conférence de presse
et il partage ce moment avec sa femme
regarder cette séquence
aidez nous
hélène que vous en pensez c'est mignon
mignon non mais c'est de toute façon
c'est mignon il partage et ça ça comment
dire ça touche toujours les
les téléspectateurs de presse aussi de
d'assister à des moments un peu perso
comme ça donc c'est mignon puis il a
bien raison de partager il a gagné
depuis sept ans sans rien faire ça se
tient lundi vit avec son temps et là
c'est très très bien pour les jeunes
joueurs et les futurs jeunes joueurs il
est je sais pas si c'est on va pas citer
des marques mais il était sur facetime
ou il est où il est sur un stade louis
ii fini story mais à priori là il
l'appelle il l'appelle en fait style
c'est c'est le moyen de communication
actuels il est dans son temps et ce
genre de geste peut faire énormément
pour le développement du de l'esprit du
golfe
on passe à notre hôtel thématique l'open
de france qui pourrait quitter
malheureusement les yvelines en 2020
pour le sud de la france l'information
n'est pas encore officielle mais la
rumeur enfle depuis plusieurs jours du 2
au 5 juillet les meilleurs golfeurs
français pourraient se retrouver non pas
sur le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
mais à terre blanche un golf de haut
niveau situé dans la campagne varoise
près de cannes
objectif redonner un nouvel élan à ce
tournoi pendant une ou plusieurs
éditions
ce changement pourrait être officiel
dans les prochains jours en écoute sur
les différentes réactions du monde
golfique présent sur le sur le dernier
open de france
le déménagement de l'open de france on
en parle actuellement mais alors il
faudra faire attention au niveau des
promoteurs parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'à un open qui sort de paris est un
open qui est en danger parce que le
nombre de spectateurs diminue de
énormément donc il faudra regarder les
chiffres et faits et faire vraiment
attention parce que il faut savoir que
l'opl organisation d'un tournoi comme ça
c'est vraiment pas donné on a la chance
de pouvoir jouer sur un des meilleurs
parcours au monde encore une fois que
tout le monde connaît aussi à la télé se
dire que s'ils demandent un super une
renault super dotation les gens qui vont
regarder ce tournoi à la télé que ce
soit les américains les européens vont
connaître par rapport à la ryder cup la
question sur ce thème pour ou contre le
déménagement de l'open de france de golf
oui ou non si vous respectez pas les
règles
donc vous êtes tous contre
ben parce que je suis chauvin est en
effet alors pour je veux enfin je suis
contre déplacement je veux qu'on garde
l'open de france ici mais à une période
beaucoup de propice
voilà le dimanche ça a quand même été
une belle et prochain se sera déplacé du
2 au 5 juillet mais voilà donc une
période plus agréable pour pouvoir jouer
au golf pour les spectateurs aussi parce
qu'on voit bien sur les images de prise
de prise d'eau que qui avait quand même
pas foule sur le
sur leur parcours en tant que média
matters à 20000 personnes à pau
c'est le nombre de spectateurs sur cette
sensibilisation sur quatre jours sauf
qu'a toujours sur quatre jours donc ça
fait cinq mille en moyenne par jour
j'imagine que le jeudi le jeudi ça
devait être on devait être bien pour
pouvoir les voir jouer a pas de souci
mais dimanche dimanche sous la flotte
c'est un calvaire
et du coup peut-être que même dimanche
barre des 10000 personnes qui sont pas
venus parce que parce que la cause de la
couche de l'afp donc voilà c'est quand
même une journée une journée une journée
catastrophe en galère pour pour la
finale
donc donc voilà il faut il faut que ce
soit joué une bonne copie c'est plus
agréable pour les mesures la météo et
puis et puis oui bien sûr qu'il faut que
ça reste en ile de france c'est de
france et la densité c'est comme les
l'ont expliqué les dans leurs reportages
si si ça s'ils vont ailleurs ben il y
aura même pas 5000 personnes sur
lesquelles jours quoi donc il faut il
faut rester il faut rester ici il faut
faire en sorte et mettre tous les tout
en place pour pour conserver l'open de
france en région parisienne
genre je donne la parole moi je suis
mitigé
je suis dit j'ai pourquoi parceque il
l'a dit à une compétition qui sort de
deux de paris et en l'occurrence du golf
national
c'est la mettre en réel mais prendre un
risque de la mettre en péril maintenant
il faut puisque le golf est en plein
plein essor on essaie de développer
cette discipline c'est bien aussi de la
faire voyager en france
alors ils le font rugby aussi quand qui
décentralise dans le nord en bretagne
dans dans l'est l'autre golf a besoin de
ça aussi de popo pour la lisibilité pour
pour montrer au public
aller chercher le public et non pas
attendre que le public vienne aller le
chercher alors c'est pour ça que je suis
un peu mitigé moi c'est que je suis un
petit peu entre les deux parce que c'est
bien d'un côté d'aller d'aller ailleurs
pour encore une fois aller chercher des
gens d'autant plus que le golf on a vu
quelques images il a l'air magnifique
aussi mais après il ya quand même il ya
quand même l'étiquette du golf national
qui de plus qui depuis on en parle on en
reparle tout le temps
cette fameuse ryder cup réussi et quand
même l'emblème et l'étiquette de 2,2 de
suprématie dans le golfe quoi donc c'est
un petit peu dommage de partir
hellemmes dans cet espace on suivre je
pense que toute façon tout a été déjà
dit je pense que j'en disais que parfois
sur rugby foot ont des centraliens
décentraliser délocalisera c'était ça
les voilà pour certains matches mais là
on parle carrément d'un tournoi et ça va
jouer sur quelques jours on parle
vraiment carrément de l'intégralité de
l'événement et pour moi c'est vraiment
dangereux de délocaliser un événement
intégralement à une ordre un endroit où
il y aura peut être potentiellement
moins de public
c'est moins bien desservie alors oui
c'est un super lieu on voit vraiment que
le green est magnifique c'est l'occasion
d'aller jouer ailleurs deux voilà
d'expérimenter à d'autres terrains mais
je pense que c'est c'est pas l'idéal
pour développer le golf ça vous plaît
pas faire la gueule ou développer un
sport c'est quand on a des cours au
plateau voilà c'est ça qui fait venir
les gens c'est que vous soyez à lille à
dunkerque enfin parlons lille ou
marseille ou ou tataouine les gens se
déplacent et donc ce qu'il faut c'est
ramener des gros plateau et c'est ça qui
fera développer le golf à l'échelle
nationale pierre il ya deux forces 10
qui s'oppose de toute façon là sur ce
choix là l'european tour qui est
promoteur de l'événement et la
fédération française de golf qui est
propriétaire de l'épreuve ils
s'affrontent depuis depuis les années de
préparation à la ryder cup et depuis
l'année 2018 sur le choix du lieu et le
choix dans la date et là dessus il ya en
premier il ya un premier positionnement
qui a été de dire en 2020 année
olympique donc année olympique qui qui
bouleverse pas mal le calendrier 2020 on
le remet en juillet et du 2 du 2 au 5
juillet 2021 et 2022 s'est pas encore
assez pas encore défini et c'est loin
d'être gagné
et en termes de lieu effectivement
l'european tour
à travers son
son exécutif directeur keith pelley dit
c'est ça se voit souvent qu'un open
national puisse puis cet itinérant et
puisse être délocalisés parfois
éventuellement pour aller à la rencontre
du public dans d'autres lieux
ce qu'il faut surtout se souvenir dans
les majeures par exemple l'open
britannique se joue jamais jamais au
même endroit c'est toujours dans un golf
britannique mais mais pas toujours le
même ça peut revenir des années
suivantes mais c'est pas c'est pas
chaque année la même chose
est ce qu'il faut ce dossier qu'il faut
se souvenir c'est que le terreau blanche
est un resort qui a été estampillé
european tour vnews c'est à dire une
parcours qui est qui et qui soit pour
les lettons in pro soit pour les soit
pour les tournois qui est qui est un
petit peu packagée européenne tour donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faudrait mettre ont
approuvé par leur peine voilà c'est ça
qui devrait mettre en avant celui là
donc on parle on parle de ça néanmoins
jean louis charon le président de la
fédération française de golf jeudi
dernier devant devant des professionnels
de gauche nous avait dit se son
nous a rappelé son attachement personnel
et l'attachement des fédérations force
des de golf de l'open de france au golf
national
pour terminer je dirai que en plus même
si c'est pas tranché puisqu'on en parle
vraiment beaucoup lui l'a démentie mais
l'european tour a encore son mot à dire
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut aussi
rappeler c'est que c'est dans un monde
dans un monde idéal on a on a cette
épreuve là qui se joue sur le sur le
parcours de la ryder cup parce que
justement c'est devenu une icône et
nikon haut niveau mondial qui se paie
lady lui ce n'est pas l'héritage de la
ryder cup c'est pas c'est pas l'open de
france c'est les retombées économiques
et tout ce que tout ce que la ryder cup
a permis de faire et notamment
il parlait des petites structures des
100 petites structures qui ont été
construites dans cette danse est dax là
et les européennes tard
open to review pardon comme comme le
complexe de terreblanche donc à suivre
ça va déjà dépendre de savoir qui est le
plus influent espira du monde
surtout alors nous le rappelait à juste
titre sera une période de vacances déjà
et on n'a pas cédé but d'évaluer des
vacances il y en a un tiers des
licenciés en fait c'est un tiers des
licenciés qui sont en ile-de-france la
réussite elle est généralement de ce
côté là la deuxième région en termes de
concentration c'est le sais pas car on
la provence et la côte d'azur
donc il y aura il y aura moins non c'est
sûr mais de là à dire qu'il n'y aura
personne non pas a priori et le site le
plein au fossat pages toujours été dans
les yvelines se déroule à chantilly en
1913 au touquet en 1921 à dieppe 123
deux villes à lyon il est à saint
quentin en yvelines depuis 91 mais là
encore il y a eu des itinérants 199 sua
au médoc ou à lyon en 2001 donc ce n'est
pas ce genre sont obligatoires
d'organiser l'open de france ici à
guyancourt janvier quelque chose de ce
que de ton intervention c'est que
apparemment le tournoi olympique est
problématique dans le calendrier aux
grands fils ben agenda mais n'hésitez
pas à laisser votre place
au niveau des du seiu s'arrangera
beaucoup de monde
hélène en plus avec vous donc finalement
on regarde ici en régime
j'aurais bien aimé maintenant on verra
si la région paca est une région où il
ya vraiment beaucoup de licenciés il y
aura forcément quand même du monde mais
c'est sûr que l'on rassemblera - le
monde là bas qu'ici voilà après faut
voir ça sera peut-être qu'une année
plusieurs années s'il ya du succès y
aura plusieurs années on aura les
réponses bientôt donc dans les
prochaines semaines on va passer
maintenant notre page coup de projecteur
on va parler à deux cyclisme la
présentation du parcours officiel du
tour de france 2020 était organisé un
mardi et le peloton s'élancera une
nouvelle fois depuis des civils pour
rejoindre les champs elysées après où en
2018 et puis rambouillet en 2019 les
yvelines vont accueillir pour la
troisième année consécutive la grande
boucle cette année c'est la ville de
mantes la jolie qui a été retenue pour
recevoir l'événement le 19 juillet
prochain
la dernière fois que la ville a vu
passer la grande boucle c'était en 2014
lors de l'étape amiens chartres on
écoute la réaction du directeur
technique national de la fédération
française de cyclisme christophe manas
il ya une approche une approche intégrée
pour arriver jusque dans paris mais mon
plat jolie ont fourgué notre 2018 qui a
qui était belle réussite avec un joli
joli parcours qui avait fait la
sélection
voilà moi je suis très heureux - le
montrent la jolie souvenez-vous le
département des yvelines et le groupe
ice organisateurs du tour de france
avait signé en mars 2019 une convention
pour accueillir les dernières étapes du
tour de france jusqu'en 2023
seule la ville de départ changera chaque
année on écoute alexandre joly vice
président délégué aux sports il nous
explique les raisons de cette convention
faut se souvenir que 2024 sera l'année
des jeux olympiques et que département
accueillera le vélo mais au-delà de ça
le vélo dans les yvelines c'est un vélo
partage c'est un vélo pour visiter c'est
aussi un vélo santé c'est un vélo pour
tous
puisque le département à 850 km de
roissy clame cette année près de vingt
mille personnes sont venues à
rambouillet pour voir le tour de france
et la victoire du colombien bernal donc
la jolie espère faire aussi bien voire
mieux
la question sur ce thème faut-il se
réjouir d'accueillir une dernière étape
du tour de france plutôt qu'une épreuve
avec du suspense ce qui n'a pas
forcément dans une dernière étape
oui j'en vous avez été le premier à
dégainer
comme souvent c'est très bien non mais
du suspense de toute façon si vous êtes
allé déjà voir et les étapes le tour de
france
mise à part les étapes en montagne ou
est pas quelque chose parce que ça passe
à une vitesse pas possible donc je pense
que c'est plus la très l'attrait de la
course par elle-même que que que le côté
le côté visuel c'est une fête et ça
attire beaucoup de monde au bord des
routes tous les ans parce que c'est la
plus grande fête en france du cyclisme
et de loin et c'est même une des plus
grandes manifestations sportives
françaises et donc les gens viennent non
pas pour encore une fois pour voir
passer les coureurs parce qu'il doit
passer tellement vite mais c'est
vraiment rendez vous on vient on vient
applaudiront vient participer
on vient passer une journée voyez qui
viennent et qui viennent avec le
casse-croûte et voilà quoi alors arrivé
après à l'étape c'est les goodies des
signatures
la caravane et voilà que c'est la magie
du tour de phrases donc son premier
amour ça se passe c'est très bien que ça
se passe dans les yvelines
hellemmes vous aviez même avis que
juillet oui c'est ce que j'en disais
c'est plus longtemps
[Rires]
les gens viennent pour l'ambiance pas
forcément pour le spectacle on est
rarement au moment où il ya une action
où quelque chose on observe on peut pas
observer ça au milieu d'aider des gens
on se drape année non voilà c'est plutôt
l'ambiance donc et puis une fin d'une
fin d'étape
voilà il ya la caravane ya tout ça il ya
le côté familial dit je suis je suis
quasiment sûr qu'il ya autant de autant
d'audience sur une dernière étape avec
les champs-elysées paris la remise du
maillot
toutes les routes de la vallée de
chevreuse qu'on connaît les routes
parisiennes et justement éventuellement
le sprint où ça peut encore bastonner un
petit peu sur sur les ronds-points
deschamps
que sur les autres étapes du tour et
effectivement jean le rappeler en
montagne oui là il ya du suspense
suspense mais mais en gros je pense que
même les spectateurs voient mieux
puisqu'il passe plusieurs fois devant
sur les champs elysées donc et d'eau qui
voit beaucoup mieux donc
réjouissons nous d'avoir cette dernière
étape qui est je pense une des plus
suivies avec les équipes de moins avec
les étapes de montagne pour voir les
cyclistes avec là encore le renfort de
piges de bosch sur les sur les sur les
champs-elysées pour la visio autant de
autant en audience mais ça ne sera pas
forcément le même même engouement à
mantes-la-jolie plutôt que sur les
champs elysées parce qu'on parlait des
différents tours mais j'ai changé je
vais avant tout lui ils vont partir mais
leurs grands parents
et justement j'ai été sur lui-même cette
année on trouve déjà été sur le départ
d'une d'une dernière étape et est
justement le gros avantage c'est que les
coureurs sont hyper abordable puisque ça
y est c'est la voilà tout est fini tout
est est donc vous pouvez aller discuter
avec les coureurs vous pouvez les
aborder avec un gris côté suspense hier
soir 9 secondes du temps de fignon est
alors après on n'est pas à l'abri
c'était signé je suis infiniment fignon
lemond je vais accepter une étape c'est
une taque contre la montre et justement
on n'est pas à l'abri que à etsaut nous
refasse une dernière étape contre la
montre à un moment ou un autre ça c est
ce qui est organisateur du tour de
france et donc il ya toujours le
contre-la-montre c'est très souvent
l'avant-dernier jour de
2 du tour voile à trélut ils l'ont fait
pendant très très longtemps ça c'est un
petit peu abandonné dernièrement mais je
crois que l'avant dernière étape sera un
contre la montre donc pourquoi pas dans
les dents les dans les trois quatre
prochaines années
avoir un contrôle à moins sur la
dernière étape ça pourrait hélas on
aurait un vrai vrai suspense et il
faudrait faire un départ de saint
quentin ou un départ de versailles pour
avoir une distance qui correspondrait à
un contrôle à moi moi je me souviens
m'être déjà fait une année enfin le
dernier contre la montre qui a eu lieu
en ile de france c'est herman la vallée
oui en effet il avoue passer une journée
complète pour voir les coureurs dès le
matin vous voyez les mecs passé pour
faire les roms et les reconnaissances et
c'est vrai que vous vous passer une très
très bonne journée
moi j'ai donc c'est positif oh bien sûr
et oui mais vraiment pareil comme thaler
j'aimerais que l'on puisse avoir un
contre la montre sur sur une étape dans
les yvelines ce serait ce serait
vraiment très très sympa en ile de
france parce que ça fait très longtemps
que ça n'a pas été ça n'a pas été fait
le dernier date au moins un temps en ile
de france vous avez des infos sur le
parcours ou pas du tout des infos sur
les prochains parcours sur le parcours
alors que je peux vous donner je vous
montre la jolie appareils du tout pas du
tout pas du tout et je trouve d'ailleurs
que mantes la jolie pour moi c'est trop
loin de paris
on sait que le dernier j'étais quand
même assez loin de paris également
rambouillet et voilà pour moi
rambouillet mantes-la-jolie ce sont deux
villes qui sont trop éloignés d'eux
de paris et on sait que la par là le
dernier la dernière table c'est d'étape
parade et donc du coup quand vous êtes
sur le devant la télé et que ben pendant
trois heures les mecs se promènent ce
problème dans la campagne yvelinoise
c'est un peu c'est un peu un peu
rébarbatif sur un garçon de paris voilà
est par contre c'est vrai que ben mine
de rien la course est belle quand les
mecs qui arrivent sur les champs qui
commence à envoyer à mettre en route
là ça on a toujours une très belle très
belle étape et moi j'encourage les gens
à aller sur les champs elysées parce que
oui en effet comme tu le disais on les
voit passer deux fois à chaque tour et
est le spectacle est vraiment sympa le
relais privilégié le cyclisme sur piste
pour qu'on voit souvent passé on voit
davantage de la piste et que l'on voit
la course toute entière il n'y a pas un
moment où on ne voit plus les cours 1 et
ça c'est vrai que c'est quand même
quelque chose de très très appréciable
on va passer notre prochaine thématique
on passe notre page résultats du
cyclisme sur piste justement dans cette
page résultat est que les championnats
d'europe la compétition s'est déroulée
la semaine dernière à appel dans nos
pays bas les pistards français qui
s'entraînait à coki 100 femmes
quotidiennement vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines ont réussi à
ramener huit médailles dans leurs
valises dont cinq en or mention spéciale
à la pistarde de 20 ans mathilde de gros
elle remporte l'or sur le keirin mention
spéciale également à quentin lafargue du
wc u sky qui remporte l'or sur le
kilomètre pour rappel cette l'épreuve
comptera dans le processus de
qualification pour les jeux olympiques
de tokyo l'année à prochaine la question
sur ce thème les français sont ils prêts
pour les jo de tokyo
quand on voit ces résultats huit
médailles dont cinq en or
c'est dans un vrai
partagé entre un petit duel entre jean
yanne jean yanne jorian jorian yann
enfin prêt pour les jo c'est dans un an
je août l'année prochaine donc j'ai
quand même encore très très loin
ce n'est qu'un championnat d'europe même
si les meilleures nations sont les
nations européennes
mais on a souvent vu des nations ne pas
envoyer leurs meilleurs athlètes sur les
championnats d'europe pour pouvoir faire
découvrir le contexte de haut niveau à
des à des futures à des futurs en
devenir alors je suis super content pour
quentin lafargue qui confirme son titre
de champion de champion du monde et avec
un super chrono en 9 000 en chant le
premier tour j'ai pas le chrono de la
finale mais voilà très très beau chrono
en qualif
mathilde qui confirme aussi sur le
terrain ça de son deuxième titre de
championne d'europe
elle est attendue et c'est bien de
pouvoir répondre quand on est quand on
est attendus et quand on a fait quand
elle est une grosse déception sur la
vitesse puisque elle est éliminée en
quarts de finale
voilà moi je peux pas dire que c'est
qu'ils sont déjà prêts parce que ben 10
mois il va se passer énormément de
choses et il ya encore énormément de
blocs de travail à réaliser pour les
pour les sprinteurs donc ça va être
vraiment très très très très long
blesson leur le temps brûlons pas les
étapes et c'est pour ça que je mets
mitigé parce que c'est une belle
réussite ce championnat ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas eu autant de
médailles autant de médailles d'or sur
un championnat international
donc ne gâchons pas notre plaisir
prenons ça avec avec grand grande
satisfaction
bravo les gars vous avez fait vous avez
fait le job mais voilà pour les jo c'est
encore voilà il aurait il reste encore
du boulot les jo c'est danser dans 10
mois et la fin de préparation est très
importante il est encore goûté on va en
l'espace de dix jours vous pouvez gagner
trois dixièmes sur sur 1 200 m si vous
faites bien les si vous faites bien de
finale donc voilà il ya encore beaucoup
de travail
genre c'est à vous il a vendu pour moi
il a fait mon boulot pas ce qui s'y dit
qu'il se passerait il vient de donner le
palmarès est ici il au fait que depuis
que des très bons résultats appuient sur
le jeune mathilde de gros quentin 20 ans
le deuxième que tu as cité
quant à 28 ans mais c'est beau il n'est
puni mais qu est ce que parce que
j'étais fier pour vos 27 ans avant de
dire non mais pour moi il ya quand on
sait qu'une révélation c'est une
confirmation
voilà pour moi pour moi ça fait quand
même un petit moment qu'on en parle sur
ce plateau
deux de ces cyclistes là et puis elle a
été blessée abandonné mathilde et là on
voit qu'elle revient qu'elle revient au
niveau international elle confirme avec
son titre de championne d'europe et je
crois que là elle est en progression
constante et ou au contraire moi je
trouve c'est ici à travers leurs
résultats aux championnats d'europe
ils confirment qu'ils confirment leur
bonne forme et leur progression et ils
vont arriver aux jeux olympiques moi je
me le pari aujourd'hui ici là qu'on aura
énormément des médailles avec ces
sportifs là aux jeux olympiques des huit
médailles dont cinq en or aussi bien
jeudi pour aussi bien mais je pense
qu'il y aura il y aura des médailles
d'or
certaines scènes mais c'était ça la
question il me semblait bien que
mathilde avaient été blessés elle l'a
redit donc c'était bien ça l est il peut
se sentir encouragée d'avoir voilà oui
nommer d'avoir réussi championnat du
monde d'europe et puis ça récompense
tout lé travail qu'elle a fourni en
s'exilant pour les perdre au japon
également pour la santé sur le siège on
voit que ça paie bien oui
non mais ça très bien pierre sainton 20
ans et l'avenir devant elle
effectivement on l'a on en parle j'en
l'a rappelé on en parle souvent sur ce
plateau là et je suis je suis d'accord
avec les avec les deux finalement yann
viennent rappeler de ne pas bouder son
plaisir parce que finalement les titres
sont pas sont pas si fréquent quand même
d en plus et en plus pas volé il reste
un an dans dans le mental et dans le
dans la préparation même physique c'est
c'est toujours mieux de glaner un titre
un an avant les jo on sait que le
contexte est différent que les que les
jeux olympiques c'est une exposition et
une pression qui vont être différentes
néanmoins arriver avec un titre de
championne de championne d'europe de
champion d'europe
voir l équipe c'est tout bon pour le
mental donc dire qu'ils sont 100% près
sûrement pas en avant il peut se passer
plein de choses il faut qu'ils se
maintiennent à ce niveau là mais en tout
cas pour le mental c'est un c'est un
grand pas en avant pour se préparer aux
jeux bien du jury faut garder cette
équipe cette équipe de france pour les
jaguars de changement bappoo religion
maintenant on est à dix mois
alors on verrouille tout ses films
j'aimerais que en effet cela se passe
comme ça en france mais malheureusement
c'est pas le cas
c'est à dire que on va les mettre en
compétition tous jusqu'au dernier moment
avec et comme il savait toujours été
fait et malheureusement c'est pas là
mais c'est pas les meilleures conditions
pour préparer les athlètes un athlète
voilà on lui dit ben il faut tu prépares
pour tel moment et a tellement fort tu
seras au top là et bien pendant les dix
prochains mois on va leur dire bah la
sélection a' va être là il va falloir tu
sois bien à ce moment là la fin et c'est
pas possible on peut pas avoir des pics
de forme doit pas garder pied dedans en
plus sont garantis parce que au dernier
moment quand le même site a été le
meilleur au mois de mars parce que
c'était les championnats du monde mais
bon peu de bordures et pour les
championnats pour les jeux olympiques
c'est arrivé à plein d'athlètes plein de
plein de fois et c'est vraiment dommage
dites-leur voilà toi tu feras les
championnats du monde quand tu feras les
jeux olympiques et faites-les créé
courir pour être au top
ah ça y est une équipe à s'être
également d'une équipe à faire une
équipe une équipe par exemple en vitesse
par équipes il faut composer avec
différents cycliste différents
caractères et gaillard tout là non parce
que comme sur une vitesse par équipes
enfin si vous courez pour les copains
mais vous pourrez tout court pour gagner
comme de départ d'une compétition donc
que vous soyez avec quelqu'un que vous
n'aimez pas quelqu'un que vous allez
quand même vous dépouiller pour pour
mettre l'équipe dans les meilleures
conditions pour pouvoir gagner à titre
personnel maintenant le problème qu'il
ya c'est que le règlement olympique est
hyper compliqué c'est complètement
différent des des quotas des quotas des
championnats du monde
vous ne pouvez pas emmener le nombre
d'êtres que vous désirez est un athlète
qui fait une compétition devra faire
automatiquement la vitesse par équipes
et s'il fait pas de commission sur piste
faut quasiment lui faire faire une
course sur la route ce qu'on a déjà vu
pour pouvoir faire la combustion paris
c'est hyper compliqué et c'est pour ça
que si le golf pour y laisser quelques
places pour simplifier les quotas des si
qsi
aujourd'hui ce serait bien
mais mais voilà donc donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de paramètres
qui ne simplifie pas les choix des
sélectionneurs
mais c'est vrai que aujourd'hui je
trouve dommage de ne pas dire à des à
des jeunes compétiteurs que ce sera
repris ils nous auront leur place et qui
n'ont que ça à jouer qu'ils n'ont que ça
à préparer je trouve ça je trouve ça un
petit peu dommage
vous êtes d'accord gens c'est très
attentifs 1 depuis tout à l'heure
oui parce que c'est vrai vous avez passé
un peu trop même
oui mais j'écoute et je buvais les
paroles de yann spécialiste du cyclisme
/ tour du monde
on passe maintenant notre dernier délai
rubrique jungle débat on va parler à
deux voiles dans ce débat et plus
précisément de la transat jacques vabre
à rambolitains louis burton va
participer à cette course au large qui
va relier le havre au brésil le
navigateur sera en duo avec l'un de ses
amis de toujours davy beaudart le départ
sera donné ce dimanche 27 octobre depuis
le havre louis burton et son coéquipier
devrait arriver à la mi novembre au
brésil s'il n'y a pas de problème sur
l'eau on écoute louis burton
c'est un objectif en soi puisque c'est à
mes yeux
la troisième course la plus importante
du plateau après le vendée globe et la
route du rhum donc il ya vraiment de
l'enjeu on est attendus sur cette course
on va être une trentaine de bateaux de
la catégorie imoca et puis c'est une
course qui en même temps en effet va
nous servira à se jauger contre les
autres pour le vendée globe puisque
quasiment tous les nouveaux bateaux qui
vont courir l'année prochaine autour du
monde sont sortis de très belles images
de notre franco belge patrick jacques de
dixmude
louis burton a déjà participé à deux
transat jacques vabre en 2013 il termine
5e et il a terminé neuvième en 2015 la
question sur ce thème doit-il passer un
palier oui ou non il a terminé 5e en
2013 9e en 2015 à 35 ans il prend un
palier de moi à chaque fois là donc il
faudrait ont dû se fasse en panne et un
beau podium ce serait formidable surtout
à la proche du vendée globe qui dit qui
soutient sera l'année prochaine ce sera
l'année prochaine
moi j'ai vu j'ai commencé à voir des
images des nouveaux bateaux c'est
magnifique quoi même quand on n'est pas
auteur même quand on n'est pas
spécialiste de deux voiles on voit là
que peut-être plus en plus de 2
enfin comment on perçoit de plus en plus
les améliorations technologiques et les
bateaux sont de plus en plus large les
feuilles la paresse et il est normal
j'ai énormément je connais des
thématiques voile va être très compliqué
on est un petit peu quand même
quand on voit les bleus bateaux qui
pêchent faut éviter les autres côté
l'édition poche du côté où l'attenté
d'un chevalier
si je ne m'abuse le jacques vabre ça
peut être de ça peut être deux et il le
vendée globe tout ça sourit donc pour
essayer de répondre à votre question le
palier il est plus dans l'est dans les
réglages et essayer tout tenter quand on
est à 2 en préparant sur le cheval sur
la jacques-vabre
et puis deux puis testé est testé à la
fois les bateaux et sa résistance perso
en se projetant bien que le l'effort
delà du vendée globe est un tout autre
et fort qu'ils soient physiques mentales
et tactiques aussi je pense que seul
objectif et juste de prendre marque avec
le bateau parce que parce que rajouter
de l'année dernière il a très rapidement
abandonnée suite un problème un problème
technique
une avarie savait pas exactement quel
est le parc du château
selon hélène par cette année c'est votre
wii passé un peu patient un palier pour
tester accord avec le même se tait sale
coup même sur le banc dès que j'ai testé
ce bateau c'est sûr parce que lui-même
et et tout tenté même avec avec un garde
au chaud puisqu'ils l'asile sont ils
sont potes il ya son pote via son pôle
média son pote qui a vécu sur les jeunes
et sur la jacques-vabre donc oui il va
passer un petit palier pour pouvoir
préparer correctement le vendée globe
qui sera une autre paire de manche ou
d'avion tic quinze jours à ccc rien oir
développe ses deux mois l année ce qu'il
faut pas qu'il gagne quand même à un
moment ou un autre
louis burton toujours gagner mais après
gagner
on aimerait tous connus pour le store au
midi ils sont trente au départ dans sa
catégorie
bayer qu'un vainqueur il ya 15 jours
alors il a un nouveau bateau justement
on l'a vu sur les images c'est bureau
vallée 2 c'est l'ancien banque populaire
qui a emporté le vendée globe le des
dernières éditions du vendée globe est
ce que finalement il sera pas un peu en
retard parce que le premier du vendée
globe 2016 partir avec un nouveau bateau
injustement yann vienne le disais est ce
que finalement il y aura pas toujours ce
petit retard qu'il empêche pas d'aller
plus haut vraiment une occasion qui
coûte cher quand même c'est pas une
première
programme c'est vrai que c'est pas il
s'appelle mais pas tous les moyens
l'idée séduit les femmes de budget un
seul bureau vallée lui rajouter quelques
allées quelques millions eh ben il aura
un bateau qui sera notre moteur mais
voilà c'est toujours ça et c'est ça moi
je sais les images que j'ai vu là c'est
le futur du vendée globe est un très
beau bateau noir là
chi chi vraiment donné l'impression
qu'il allait lui n'allait pas tout chez
lui il n'allait pas volé sur voila il
n'avait pas touché il n'avait pas bu
vous guide penché il avait volé tout
droit et il y avait ni le bateau la
rigole encore il va partir avec davy
beaudart skipper inexpérimentés parce
que ça va jouer son copain lui fondu il
lui faut donc si j'allais dire ça mais
c'est passer l'info en course de
l'histoire du fonds un contexte
favorable et ce sera parfait
le coéquipier parce que si mamad moi par
exemple qui souhaitent partir deux mois
pour faire le vendée globe là il va
faire une traversée de 15 jours en effet
il est capable d'emmener des gens là
c'est dévaloriser et une est comme ça
c'est dévaloriser non mais c'est gilles
valoriser j'ai des bons côtés mais
d'idées des livres d'art davy beaudart
se dévaloriser vous rendez compte mon
chien il suivit il a quand même gagné
des courses mais pas des grosses courses
mais il a quand même participé à de
nombreuses courses
oui c'était du bonheur ou plus
inexpérimentés c'est mieux c'est bien
pour ça totem et c'est bien pour ça il y
là mais la carrière quelqu'un qui paye
pour pour gagner sur une course de toute
façon mais quand on bouge le temps
d'apercevoir ce qui compte aussi c'est
les commentaires les avariée
potentiellement rencontrer la façon de
gérer les crises etc
les pannes les casse mais chose comme ça
donc on verra aussi les émeutes anti de
travail dans des chantiers navals du
coup il pourra réparer le bateau en cas
de mal à voir aussi pour concerne les
résultats ça rentre monde des livres
d'art vous donnons donc s'appelle guy
petit toit qui sera très compétitif
complémentaires tout à fait
[Applaudissements]
on va passer à notre dernière thématique
très rapidement c'était la fête dans les
tribunes du stade mob auront de
versailles dans le cadre de la trêve
internationale la guinée les comores ce
sont affrontés ce samedi en match amical
non content il est dit sur cette pelouse
qui a plutôt l'habitude de voir évoluer
des équipes de nationale 3 c'est festif
ça fait vraiment plaisir de voir de voir
le stade et les tribunes pleines et une
ambiance chaleureuse
voilà qui les gens qui viennent
supporter leur sélection ça fait
vraiment c'est vraiment sympa le rendez
vous a attiré des milliers de supporters
des deux équipes venus pour encourager à
leurs protégés surtout analyser le
niveau de jeu des deux équipes en pleine
préparation en vue des éliminatoires de
la prochaine coupe d'afrique des nations
jouent en ile de france y joue plutôt
souvent
en espagne
en afrique nous sommes venus de
bruxelles uniquement pour ce match c'est
la patrie ça n'a pas de prix en après on
importe quelle distance gweny le booster
pour la petite histoire les communs ont
longtemps porté sur la plus petite des
marges sur le score de 1 but à 0 vu le
succès rencontré pour cette affiche la
ville de versailles n'exclut pas
d'organiser d'autres rencontres
internationales dans l'est à prochaines
années la question sur ce thème des
matches internationaux à versailles est
ce que c'est une bonne idée
oui le versailles et ses adversaires il
est satisfait la seule chose c'est qu'il
n'ya pas encore une communication
suffisamment large pour permettre
d'avoir une une assistance plein et une
stade comble je ne lasse des tableaux
des jeux d'écart
donc je vois la main de fer plus de pub
que ça parce que et c'est pareil c'est
quoi la capacité du time bomb a vécu à
peu près 4000 personnes
je pense d'accord j'ai gagné il est donc
c'est très bien tout les touts les
toutes les occasions qui peuvent ramener
du monde sur du sport national
départemental internationale notamment à
versailles c'est une très bonne chose
très bonne exposition et notamment pour
relayer les supporters des deux équipes
il faut bien calibré comme parce que
justement le 4000 places ça veut dire
que on peut pas faire
france brésil par exemple c'est pas
possible on peut pas faire on peut on
peut tenter on peut le jouer on peut le
laisser faire de ce genre c'est quand
même assez long mais c'est très bien ils
sont et c'est physique
non tout satisfait tout le monde avait
l'air content heureux de commandes ball
club l'année un peuple il était content
il était il était hyper content de voir
autant de monde dans les tribunes de ne
pas voir qu'un gros temps soit donc
voilà on sort des matches de national
plus aisés où ils sont vingt deux
personnes avec doc là ça fait vivre un
petit peu c'est toujours bien pour un
président en plus de voir son nom avec
modération neige puis là je pense pas
qu'il y ait beaucoup
non non c'est très très bien et c'est
très très bien sont favorisés seront
chaudes hellemmes
je suis d'accord tu pas de tonnes d'or
alors l'irlande était déjà venu en 2016
pendant l'euro l'angleterre est
également venu en rugby poule à lors de
la coupe du monde 2007
est ce que finalement vers s'inscrit
dans ce projet sportif
le grand événement sportif toujours il
ya toujours des dossiers en cours et
notamment pour
rugby pour 2023 ou versailles est aussi
candidate pour accueillir un camp de
base
donc oui versailles a des atouts
indéniables par rapport à aux eyzies aux
exigences du sport international quel
que soit le sport on a vu aussi le foot
féminin ya pas si longtemps avec la
préparation de la coupe du monde la
coupe du monde
et puis et puis le camp de base aussi
pas très loin donc
donc oui il ya versailles a des atouts à
faire valoir justement pour accueillir
des équipes internationales
quel que soit son prix si tu souhaites
assez près de paris ben voila je suis à
la rime
une galerie une hôtellerie deux qualités
aussi dans le secteur avec avec le
trianon et puis donc donc voilà dia qui
peuvent loger des joueurs aller recevoir
toutes les facilités tout autour des
nombreux lacs et structures sportives
synthétique c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission merci d'être venus déguisés en
europe par contre que les chapeaux ne
sont pas laissés sur les têtes ou les
masques sur le visage masques vont
tomber les masques sont tombés
on va terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui focus sur une
citation golfique d'un écrivain anglais
arnold holstein à chaque parcours on
trouve 18 pièces de théâtre parfois
tragiques parfois comique
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 78 et bien bonne
halloween
[Musique]